i was shocked of course i was shocked
tasia adams is opening up about stepping
into her new role as the bachelorette
host with caitlin bristow
the two former franchise leads
tag-teamed hosting duties for katie
thurston's upcoming season of the
bachelorette replacing chris harrison
after he announced his decision to step
away from the franchise
after the fallout for his apparent
defense of bachelor contestant rachel
curcanell's past
racially insensitive actions this is a
very unprecedented time
and this has just been something that's
been so fun for both of us caitlin and i
really just created this really fun
dynamic duo
that has never been done before with the
bachelorette and i feel like it really
provided a lot of i don't know strength
behind katy and confidence as well
because you're in that situation and
sometimes you don't know what to do
and we were able to provide a little bit
of clarity and help for her you know
katie is a strong
confident woman that knows what she
wants and she's not afraid to do what
she has to do to get that so
it's gonna be good while we wait to see
katie's journey to find
love tasha and caitlyn have their own
weddings to plan
kayla's engaged i'm so excited for her i
knew it was coming sometime soon i just
had a feeling
but um i'm so happy for both of them
tasha is engaged to her bachelorette
finalist
zach clark and caitlin recently got
engaged to fellow bachelor nation alum
jason tartick oh my god
caitlyn and i have been talking about
wedding stuff since we were filming so
i'm sure down the road because it just
happened now she's in mexico we'll talk
about it since
sometime soon i'm just getting my feet
wet in new york city it's the sun is
finally out it's not
freaking cold outside anymore so i'm
just enjoying the city for now but zach
and i are doing
well and i'm sure wedding planning will
start sometime soon tasia who first
appeared on colton underwood season of
the bachelor
also reacted to his recent coming out as
gay
you know i haven't spoken to him but i'm
just happy he's able to
live in his truth and be happy
you